Peak TV is here to stay, with networks and
streaming services already lining up exciting
new series for years to come.
Looking ahead to next year, we're already
excited for a slew of shows with huge stars
on both sides of the camera—and intriguing
and interesting premises ready to bring new
perspectives to the small screen.
Get ready to make plenty of room in your queue,
because these are just some of the many TV
shows you can look forward to watching in
2018.
Black Lightning
The CW is taking on a more mature superhero
with Black Lightning, a former masked vigilante
who spent years keeping the streets safe.
Starring Cress Williams as Jefferson Pierce,
the show will follow his close calls fighting
local gang the One Hundred and how his wife
convinced him to quit for the sake of his
daughters.
After years of safely operating as a high
school principal, though, Jefferson is eventually
called back into crime fighting as the One
Hundred takes over the town again.
He'll eventually enlist the aid of his daughters
Jennifer and Anissa, who'll take on the identities
Thunder and Lightning.
Black Lightning reportedly won't initially
be set in the Arrow-verse with the rest of
the CW's superhero shows, which offers up
a lot of creative freedom for the series to
establish its own tone and pace once this
show lands on-screen January 16th.
The Alienist
TNT is going period for their next prestige
drama, The Alienist.
This psychological thriller stars Daniel Bruhl
as Dr. Laszlo Kreizler, an expert searching
for the person responsible for the demise
of several boys in New York City.
The cast also includes Luke Evans as his partner,
and Dakota Fanning as a woman with hidden
information related to their search.
Kreizler will stop at nothing.
"Even if it leads me to the darkest pit of
hell."
Think of it as Mindhunter with a late 19th
Century twist.
The Alienist lands on the small screen January
22nd.
A.P. Bio
Following his turn in It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia, Glenn Howerton's newest series
puts him in the lead.
Titled A.P. Bio, the sitcom comes from Saturday
Night Live alums Seth Meyers and Lorne Michaels.
Howerton will play a philosophy scholar who
loses out on his dream job and goes to work
as a high school biology teacher.
Realizing he has a room full of honor roll
students at his disposal, he decides to eschew
teaching biology and instead use the kids
to his own benefit.
The show is set to debut midseason on NBC.
"It is a very f---ed up reflection of how
things are."
The Ballad of Buster Scruggs
The Coen brothers are scheduled to jump on
the Netflix bandwagon in 2018 with The Ballad
of Buster Scruggs, which follows six stories
about the American frontier, with each chapter
of the anthology focusing on a different plot.
Tim Blake Nelson will portray the titular
singing cowboy in the first episode, with
other A-listers coming in to round out the
rest of the season's stars, including Stephen
Root, Ralph Ineson, James Franco, and Zoe
Kazan.
Westerns have a complicated history on the
small screen, but if anyone can do it, it's
the guys who brought us True Grit and No Country
for Old Men.
Castle Rock
Stephen King stories are always prime fodder
for adaptations, and Hulu is looking to jump
back in the game with the 10-episode psychological
thriller, Castle Rock.
The anthology show, which will follow different
sets of characters from King's novels, will
revolve around the fictional Maine town featured
in King-based movies like Stand By Me, Cujo,
and Needful Things.
Andre Holland is set to star as Henry, a death
row attorney with a unique and complicated
history.
And the cast is full of people who should
be familiar to fans of adaptations of King's
work, including Carrie's Sissy Spacek and
It's Bill Skarsgård.
The show is rounded out by an ensemble that
includes Melanie Lynskey, Jane Levy, and Scott
Glenn.
With King's properties at peak popularity
right now, this small screen homage to his
literary world is bound to be a hit.
Cloak and Dagger
Multiple Marvel series are set to hit your
screens in 2018, but Freeform's Cloak and
Dagger looks like one of the most exciting.
The show stars Olivia Holt as Tandy Bowen,
a.k.a.
Dagger, a teen raised with the ability to
emit light daggers who is forced to adapt
after a storm uproots her life.
Meanwhile, Aubrey Joseph appears as Tyrone
Johnson, a.k.a.
Cloak, a teen who can engulf people in darkness.
The trailer teases the series' bigger connections
to the MCU, ending with Tyrone standing on
top of the Roxxon Corporation building—an
evil entity featured in other Marvel properties.
With potentially bigger implications along
with their grounded story, we're excited to
see this superhero pair in action.
Cobra Kai
The Karate Kid has already gotten a big-screen
modern remake, but Cobra Kai promises to be
something else entirely.
This new show, set to premiere on YouTube
Red, will reunite original franchise stars
Ralph Macchio and William Zabka to show what
happened to the pair after the events of the
initial 1980s trilogy.
Taking place more than 30 years after the
fateful events of the 1984 All Valley Karate
Tournament, the new series will see Johnny
looking for redemption by reopening the titular
dojo—and reigniting his rivalry with Daniel.
While Daniel is now successful in life, he's
struggling to find balance without the help
of his mentor Mr. Miyagi, who was played in
the original film by the late Pat Morita.
The pair will address their past and present
frustrations through, of course, karate.
Get ready to pencil a YouTube Red subscription
into your budget, because this is a series
you won't want to miss.
Untitled animated Deadpool series
The Merc with a Mouth is taking over the silver
screen again when Deadpool 2 hits theaters
in 2018, but the character will also get some
small screen action courtesy of an animated
FXX series from Donald Glover.
Glover, who made his MCU debut over the summer
in Spider-Man: Homecoming, is set to write,
executive produce, and serve as co-showrunner
on the series alongside his brother Stephen.
The adult-oriented action-comedy isn't expected
to hew too closely to what we've already seen
in theaters, though.
FX head John Landgraf said the tone of the
series will be "really different" from the
movies, and the goal is to make something
distinct from Ryan Reynolds' take on the character.
"And remember: hugs not drugs."
Jack Ryan
Although the Jack Ryan movies have been hit
or miss in theaters, this eight-episode Amazon
series might breathe new life into the Tom
Clancy character.
The show will feature John Krasinski in the
title role -- which was previously held in
the films by Alec Baldwin, Harrison Ford,
Ben Affleck, and Chris Pine.
And the show will follow the up-and-coming
CIA analyst as he unravels a pattern of terrorist
communication that could threaten the whole
world.
The rest of the cast includes Wendell Pierce
as Jack's boss James Greer, Abbie Cornish
as Cathy Mueller, and others, so count on
this to be an action-adventure for the ages.
"Holy s---."
Krypton
There are already quite a few superhero shows
on TV right now, but Syfy's Krypton looks
like a different take on the crowded genre.
Set on the titular planet 200 years before
the birth of Superman, it shows how the House
of El was shamed and ostracized.
The series will follow Superman's grandfather
Seyg-El on his quest to bring hope and equality
to Krypton, turning a planet in disarray into
one worthy of giving birth to the greatest
superhero ever known.
Fans can expect to see a lot of familiar elements
from the comics, including the villain Brainiac
and Seyg-El's unlikely human mentor Adam Strange.
Origin stories are always iffy, but with Superman's
ancestors at the fore here, this should be
an otherworldly adventure worth watching.
Mosaic
HBO is going experimental for their upcoming
Steven Soderbergh series Mosaic, which follows
the aftermath of a homicide.
Olivia Lake, a famed children's author, goes
missing after romance blossoms with a mysterious
stranger.
But this won't be your typical mystery series—through
a mobile app, viewers will be able to create
their own adventure as they delve into the
twisty plot.
Viewers will get to choose their point of
view and which story to follow, with each
choice building on the others, enabling the
tale to be told in a multitude of different
ways and ending in different conclusions.
The app will give viewers a few months to
play with it before Soderbergh unveils his
official take on the story in a six-episode
series in January of 2018.
If Soderbergh's name and HBO's innovative
method of presenting the content aren't enough
to get you on board, it also has some big
stars attached, including Sharon Stone, Garrett
Hedlund, Beau Bridges, and Paul Reubens.
Experiments are popular in the age of peak
TV, and this seems like one that could succeed
in a big way.
New Warriors
The New Warriors may not currently have a
TV home, but they're expected to hit the small
screen at some point in 2018.
Marvel's first comedy series was initially
set to debut on Freeform, but it was eventually
pulled from the network, which wouldn't have
been able to fit it on its schedule.
Although the fact that Freeform dropped the
series is definitely worrisome, New Warriors
is still setting up to be a lot of fun.
The series is set to bring the very popular
Squirrel Girl to live action, with Milana
Vayntrub taking on the role.
Other stars include Derek Theler as Mister
Immortal, Jeremy Tardy as Night Thrasher,
Calum Worthy as Speedball, Matthew Moy as
Microbe, and Kate Comer as Debrii.
The series follows the six aforementioned
young people as they deal with their powers
while trying to make a difference in the world—even
if the world isn't ready.
And since they live and work together, the
series is sure to provide quite a lot of tension
and comedy.
Untitled Purge series
The Purge franchise has done very well on
the big screen, and now it's coming to TV.
Blumhouse Television is set to bring a Purge
"interwoven anthology" show to USA and Syfy
next year.
Franchise and show creator James DeMonaco
has said that he wants the TV series to spend
more time delving further into the characters'
motivations, emphasizing a side of the Purge
that the movies have not had a chance to explore.
DeMonaco believes this will make Purge Night
seem even more intense, as people are more
familiar with the characters and understand
their full arcs.
Although we don't know who'll star in the
show yet, this seems like an interesting take
on a popular horror series.
Rise
Friday Night Lights meets Glee in 2018 courtesy
of NBC's Rise.
Based on the 2013 book Drama High, Rise follows
Josh Radnor as Lou, a high school English
teacher who works in the theater department
in a Rust Belt town in Pennsylvania.
He decides to reinvigorate the school's drama
students through their performance of the
hit musical Spring Awakening.
The cast also includes Auli'i Cravalho, who
will play a student named Lilette, and Shannon
Purser, who has a recurring role as a student
named Annabelle.
Rosie Perez plays the high-energy drama teacher
Tracey, while Rarmian Newton will play a mysterious,
independent student who works as the school's
lighting technician.
This Is Us may currently have the monopoly
on NBC's tearjerker slot, but we're on board
with another good cry every week.
"Let's dream.
Big."
The Romanoffs
Mad Men creator Matthew Weiner is taking on
Russian royalty with his Amazon anthology
series The Romanoffs, which follows people
who believe they're descended from the famous
Romanov family.
The last imperial dynasty to rule Russia,
the Romanovs were eliminated by revolutionaries,
but some speculate that one daughter, Anastasia,
survived the attack.
As many as four of the episodes will be set
in the United States, while four will be set
and filmed abroad.
The show has an all-star cast on board, including
Diane Lane, Aaron Eckhart, Isabelle Huppert,
Christina Hendricks, John Slattery, Jack Huston,
Amanda Peet, Corey Stoll, and Paul Reiser.
Given the impressive work Weiner delivered
on Mad Men and the anthology approach he's
taking with this series, The Romanoffs sounds
like an intriguing new take on an old mystery.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!